[Musique]
et c'est l'heure donc de la chasse aux
fausses informations un fond intox avec
vous Antoine fenaud bonjour bonjour
Raphaël et direction aujourd'hui est
l'Ukraine ou une carte faible doute
absolument Raphaël une carte tout plus
précisément une vidéo même vous allez la
percevoir c'est cette vidéo ici que je
vais vous montrer un instant si mon
matériel vieux bien répondre voilà nous
la voyons juste ici qu'est-ce qu'on y
voit un homme qui tient un livre dans sa
main il ouvre à l'intérieur qu'est-ce
qu'on voit Descartes de l'Ukraine
qu'est-ce qui nous affirme cet homme
dans cette vidéo et bien je vais vous
livrer ce qu'il dit il dit c'est la
nouvelle réalité ce manuel il le
présente comme étant la nouvelle édition
d'un manuel de géographie destinée au
lycéen ukrainien il dit regardez cette
cette ce manuel prend en compte la
nouvelle réalité car la carte de
l'Ukraine que vous voyez ici est amputée
on ne voit plus personne on ne voit plus
denience qu'on voit plus louant ce qu'on
ne voit plus lui vive sous-entendu et
bien vous l'avez compris les Ukrainiens
prennent déjà en compte la de l'avancée
russe cette vidéo elle a également
beaucoup de circuler sur les chaînes
télégram prorus vous la percevez ici
avec cette internaute qui reprend
également les affirmations que l'on
voyait dans la vidéo ou encore plus et
plus précisément celle-ci ou la
carrément on voit exactement vous voyez
là la carte en question que l'homme dans
cette vidéo nous montre Raphaël mais
problème Antoine cette carte scolaire et
bien il n'existe pas absolument et pour
s'en rendre compte il faut simplement
taper le à une simple recherche d'image
inversée avec la couverture la
couverture du livre que vous voyez juste
ici et bien nous en font un truc on a
juste retrouvé c'est la couverture de ce
livre et on l'a retrouvé sur des sites
Internet qui nous le proposent à la
vente ce livre et bien c'est un manuel
de géographie naturellement destiné aux
élèves
Ukrainiens la maison d'édition elle
s'appelle cartographie et elle peut vous
proposer ce livre qui s'appelle donc
carte des contours de l'histoire de
l'Ukraine le problème et c'est là que ça
devient intéressant c'est que mais cette
maison d'édition elle nous l'avons
contacté et elle nous affirmait bien que
ce livre que l'on voit ici cette vidéo
et bien ne représente absolument pas la
dernière édition de son livre qui
contient ces pages et des cartes et bien
cette maison d'édition est bien elle
nous les a envoyés en voici un exemple
juste là voici les fonds de cartes donc
comme on les qualifie vous savez en
géographie chez les élèves ce sont des
fonds de cartes avec des questions que
vous apercevez ici que auquel les élèves
doivent répondre donc n'abons autour des
populations de répartition de population
de l'Ukraine et bien pour s'en rendre
compte au-delà de croire et bien cette
maison d'édition sur parole il suffit de
ces suffisait de regarder plusieurs
détails qui étaient intrigants dans la
vidéo je vais vous la remontrer on va
remonter un petit peu plus loin voilà
juste ici cet homme et bien la première
chose que l'on voit c'est que juste là
vous voyez une agrafe présente dans
cette vidéo ici vous ne voyez absolument
pas d'agraphe la couleur également est
totalement différente et ici on ne se
rend compte qu'il n'y a pas de numéro de
page de numéro de page que l'on retrouve
juste ici et notamment avec le titre du
chapitre et ce cet ouvrage est bien ce
conclu par cette carte ci de l'Ukraine
on voit qu'elle est totalement
différente et qu'elle reprend bien
évidemment naturellement toutes les
frontières de l'Ukraine vous l'avez donc
compris rafale il s'agit là encore d'une
infox pro-rus et d'info il faut bien
dire assez grossier et on en reste pas
là Antoine on continue sur l'Ukraine
avec une autre info cette fois sur les
Lego oui absolument une infox un peu
plus légère vous allez vous allez le
comprendre elle a notamment circulé vous
le voyez vous allez l'apercevoir juste
ici notamment autour de ces tweets cet
homme notamment en espagnol s'indigne
vous voyez avec ces images notamment de
l'ego qu'on voit grimer en soldat avec
des petits brassards jaunes et des logos
de l'armée ukrainienne autour de leur de
leurs bras et cet homme dit voilà et
bien l'ego annonce des figurines du
bataillon Asos rien que ça quand est-ce
ironise-t-il va-t-on voir des des
figurines d'Al-Qaïda ou bien encore de
Lexis donc c'est à dire de
l'organisation état islamique il faut
dire que cette
ces photos ont largement circulées
notamment en anglais vous le voyez ici
ce tweet reprenant exactement les mêmes
photos il a cumulé lui presque 1000 200
like et le problème est bien évidemment
vous vous en doutez et bien c'est que
bien évidemment l'ego n'a jamais fait de
figurines du bataillon Azov et ça pour
s'en rendre compte il suffit encore une
fois de faire une simple une simple
recherche d'images inversée on retombe
sur la photo originale la voici elle est
elle émerge de cet homme qui s'appelle
Andrew berkraft et cet homme est bien il
fabrique lui-même des petites figurines
LEGO il est fabrique lui-même pour
rendre hommage notamment ici vous le
voyez c'était pour le siège de Mario
Paul il le précise ici ce sont des
figurines customisées ce ne sont pas des
produits officiels donc il faut savoir
que cet homme Andrew berkraft et bien il
dispose également d'un bloc on a pu
retrouver s'appelle the brother bricks
où il avec d'autres internautes et bien
il partage leur passion où ils font des
petits montages où la percevez ici Lego
j'ai choisi ici cette page au hasard où
on aperçoit donc on aperçoit un un
bateau avec ce petit montage de Lego là
encore il ne s'agit pas de figurine
officielle Lego il le précise lui
également dans son blog il s'agit de
figurines utilisées par cette société
qui s'appelle brick Mania vous le voyez
ici j'ai que fait une capture d'écran de
leur site web et ils le précise bien
dans leur page laissez cette société que
ils ne sont pas une compagnie officielle
légaux qui ne produisent pas
effectivement de figurines LEGO là pour
en un on commence à en mettre à peu près
sûr et si on voulait définitivement et
bien s'en apercevoir et bien il
suffisait juste de d'interroger
carrément la compagnie Lego ce que nous
avons fait nous car nous sommes
déterminés pertinents vous vous en
doutez ici à un photoc c'est bien nous
avons contacté l'ego qui nous dit ces
produits ne sont pas des produits légaux
officiels ne sont qu'à aucun cas associé
au Lego voilà donc une sorte de petite
infox par
omission autour de quelqu’un qui s'est
visiblement bien mal enseigné et voilà
une fox démontée par vos soins et celui
bien sûr de les équipes de France 24
d'un fond intox merci Antoine fenaud